all right let's check this out let's
talk let's talk about some serious covet
stuff right now
because this one's probably going to get
a little bit in trouble on youtube daily
mail reports is this the link between
astrazeneca's covet vaccine and blood
clots shot may trigger an immune
response that leads to the
life-threatening side effect in rare
cases
study claims they say about 30 cases of
blood clots among people who got a dose
of astrozenecos vaccine were reported in
europe
german researchers found signs of
antibodies that attack platelets in the
blood of nine people
who developed the clots after getting
the shot these antibodies destroy the
platelets
to make up for the loss the body over
produces platelets causing them to clot
the team says that if their hypothesis
is correct the reaction can
can be identified and easily treated by
medical professionals
more than 20 european countries paused
the use of asergenica's shot this month
amid clot fears but subsequently resumed
its use
officials in the eu ruled the rate of
clots was not above that in the general
population
but canada on monday issued a pause on
the use of vaccine for under 55s
citing concern over clots this is the
kind of stuff that freaks me out
because we've seen a bunch of stories
and this is what pisses me off a bunch
of stories where they're like man gets
shot
shortly after dies and then you read the
stories like one month later he died and
he was 75 years old and i'm like come on
man
like dude we really need to know about
this stuff and you got a bunch of media
that wants to just freak us out and
scare us
this is legit though and i wouldn't be
surprised if youtube gets mad at us for
even talking about it but this is a
legit news guard certified source daily
mail
and they're saying in europe they
suspended it briefly in canada they're
suspending it
so i don't know what you guys think
about this but this to me
i think you know they're going to go
after people calling them anti-vaxx
if they bring anything like this up and
that's the more dangerous thing in my
opinion
yeah yeah because i mean it's a real
thing that's happening the governments
are having to suspend it
but then if you're critical of it or if
you're skeptical or if you're
nervous about taking it yourself then
you're this like crazy anti-vaxx monster
who believes disinformation
and you can't even discuss it so
everybody's like hiding in shame being
like
freaked out about this thing and nobody
can even talk about it vaccines are
amazing
amazing technology but if they're
misused they're super dangerous
and can kill people so that's why they
have this massive testing and
they make them go through years of
trials and stuff
why would you ever want to put yourself
in a position where you might get blood
clots
for something unless that thing is super
deadly and like gonna mur
like gonna [ __ ] you or something
what we have to look at is the rate at
which people got blood clots
and the covet survival rate for someone
who's under 55
i gotta tell you i don't see a reason
why people who are under 55
should be taking a medication that's
been suspended by the government if
canada says don't take it then the
people in canada probably can't do it
which means the passport thing the whole
vaccine passport thing is broken
it's not going to work the survival rate
for people under 55 i think is what like
99.995 or some
really really high number super high
young people are not
being negatively impacted by this it's
almost like a large
voting block of older people are worried
about this
and pushing for this and that's kind of
like been the narrative
for most of my life older people wanted
social security
so they vote to put money into it and
they take from it the system collapses
it's always been like
jesus look at congress they're all like
not all of them but a lot of them are
over 70.
i mean nancy pelosi is what she's 80
right yeah super old
a very broken system when you're
sacrificing your children to save the
old
i i everybody's going to call me a
monster for saying that i guess but
our children are committing suicide at
super high rates right now they're
they're suffering from depression their
you know abused children are stuck at
home
and not seeing teachers who could get
them out of that situation there's all
these like horrible
negative effects of what they're doing
for children right now
and i mean all of this comes down to
people who are older are afraid and so
we're sacrificing our youth in
multiple ways um we've seen these like
these videos of the kids sitting at
their desks and they're six feet apart
and surrounded by plexiglass
it's horrible these kids are gonna be
very very
developmentally stunted did you see the
mother of the giving birth and there's a
plastic tarp between her and the baby
and she like squeezes the baby against
the plastic creepy
babies like in his face smushed on the
plastic i thought i thought
babies in like the super young were not
were like fine like covert wasn't
affecting them they like kids in schools
weren't being affected or whatever
yeah people are living in terror and
they're being harassed dude
these stories i'll tell you the big
problem is that
a sane and rational population would say
hey you know canada is suspending this
over blood clot fears
should we consider something like that
in the u.s and and look to these other
countries in terms of
their medical prowess and endeavors i
mean we hear all the time from the left
about the health care systems of these
other countries being infinitely better
than ours
there was recently a story where i guess
like norway was was calling
the us an underdeveloped medical uh
system
which is just ridiculous by the way it
was clearly just the stupidest thing
ever
like you may talk about the the payment
systems being screwed up in
pharmaceutical companies and the way the
money goes in the insurance companies
fine but we got advanced technology here
in terms of medicine
but they were mocking the us saying
underdevelop it was like be wary of
traveling countries with underdeveloped
healthcare systems for example the
united states
hahaha very funny yet tons of people
come here for medication
anyway the point is if we can't have a
conversation
about okay fine these other countries
are taking this seriously
then we're in trouble yeah and that's it
it's almost as if we have an
overly qualified medical like our
basically what i'm thinking about is
potassium bromate or i think it's
bromide or bromate it's a leaving agent
and bread
that's cause causes cancer it's been
known to be
whether carcinogenic and europe most of
europe has banned it from their bread
products but the united states has not
so it's a big problem that the medical
that the pharmaceutical
chemical industry has more sway than
common sense sometimes what i'm saying
is that
i'm talking about the media i'm talking
about the fact that we'll be like
wow canada is suspending their their
their their you know vaccine for people
under 55.
they're going to call scientificers
they're going to insult me smear and say
they were
questioning it it's like no dude and the
leavening agent
is obviously there's evidence that it's
carcinogenic yet the media why would the
media not be like well let's get it out
of our bread products if it's causing
cancer
they don't care like that's that's not
in the news cycle they want to sell that
stuff
brominated vegetable oils and like oh
it's so bad for people too
sure sure like evidently the media cares
about
protecting the status quo and the
establishment there's no
national conversation about bromine
there's a national conversation about
covet and vaccines
and so they want to toe the line they
want to mimic the status quo and they
want to write what other outlets write
and if they find you as an other it'll
work i think
the big problem it's really annoying to
me are we are we really in the minority
are we the silent majority is it
which is it is is this country 80 a
bunch of really dumb
people who are like i'm not going to
talk about anything and i'm going to sit
here and plug my ears and just do
whatever i'm told
terrifyingly the data says yes i think
that it's like 90
of people are kind of followers yeah see
now that i'm in my my beautiful
right-wing bubble
in west virginia i just can't like
it seems like everybody doesn't want it
and that everybody
has common sense about it that you know
they think that people who are very
elderly
should take it and that people who are
younger should not
um and that's just like the common all
the conversations that you have with
people
in my neighborhood that's what it is and
then
you see it online and everybody just
acts like that's a completely crazy
unreasonable fringe take
so it it's very disconnected for me i
saw something really funny today
it was brian stelter from reliable
sources saying asking if the
nash if the white house press corps like
the the national press is out of sync
with the american people or whatever
and i'm like man it took you this long
wow it's been like children who are
wrong
yeah six years it's the yeah are we out
of sync
you know what i realize is really funny
when there was a story in the new york
times
about a party someone from the new york
times had been to a few years prior
and they were like canceled over it or
something and i'm like what
regular american is like i'm going to
turn to the new york times for the
important news
janet went to a party three years ago
and got cancelled for being racist
wow that's the news i pay for but people
pay for it
their subscribers are it's going up
they're making more and more money
journalists write about each other and
i'm like who are you talking to yeah
what who is this but you know what man
it's frustrating because
i was at you know we went out to a bar
the other day and there was a guy who
made a really great point he said
look the vaccine's here it's available
we're done
it should be over if you don't want to
get it that's your problem i'll be fine
because he was like he said he was
getting the vaccine and i'm like
totally agree why should we have a
vaccine passport system
why should we mask mandate or any social
distancing when the people who get the
vaccines will be fine
if someone chooses not to get it well
then you're the one person who's going
to get it nobody else will
i don't understand the logic the logic
is if you don't get the vaccine and you
carry it
then you can transport it to other
people or but if you're vaccinated
you're fine according to fouchy you may
still need to wear a mask because you're
not immune if you get the vaccine
you're not what do you say i i wanted to
speak to this because fauci and joe
biden
all these people are still wearing masks
after they've gotten the vaccine
what is the point of getting a vaccine
if nothing changes i'm starting to feel
like they're waging a war of
demoralization on the american people
and this is still an idea in development
because they don't understand why
they're doing it they don't
know if the vaccine is effective we are
the test they do they do
they do know if it's effective i mean
they've done numerous tests the issue is
is it is safety versus freedom it is
easier for them to be like
i would rather just be safe peter
hitchens wrote this
or this op-ed about getting the vaccine
and he was like you know i got the
vaccine and all it cost me was my
freedom
and i'm like look man i think the bigger
issue is that there's no trust
in our public institutions anymore we're
hyper-polarized and we don't like each
other
because if we were actually a unified
country combating this great
villain we would be like yes we got to
get everyone vaccinated we'd be like
cheering for it
would be only a few people who opposed
it yeah exactly everyone
comes together right no we're fractured
nobody trusts each other the media's
garbage
they're like writing about each other
and another
other nonsense they write about oh no
glenn greenwald we got to write about
him now who cares
stop writing about other people that's
the problem with a lot of it the media
really
killed their credibility during the
trump administration i mean they were
selling the american public
a horror movie and now
they don't have much else to write about
so they're trying to create all these
villains and
and everybody's just like what are you
doing like none of this is relevant to
me
and so when they do put out information
about things like vaccines or kovid
people are skeptical rightly because for
years we've been fed russiagate
and all this crazy nonsense from the
media
like all this stuff that's just like
completely insane that they've been
feeding us for so long
how are you supposed to trust them when
there's something actually serious
um i look at this some i agree with that
russiagate was so stupid
didn't have evidence i mean or maybe it
didn't have enough evidence to to
warrant that amount of
what's her name the girl with the short
hair yeah maddow's obsession with it for
two years it was like she like
cried oh my god but what i'm thinking
about is
a level of cognitive dissonance also
that we're looking at because i think
that
obesity is a big part of this epidemic
and like what sixty percent of people
what were these numbers i want to get
this at sixty percent of people that
have coveted are obese
or sixty percent of people that are
obese yeah that's insane 78
of covet patients were obese well but
look you know i'll add to this
people who are out of shape unhealthy
and sick
are much more likely to die in general
and so you add in
you know covid which is i think the
mortality rate's like double the flu so
it's like substantially higher
and you're going to get a ton of people
who are who have co-morbidities dying
from this thing and if they're lucky
people
i don't want to stop drinking pepsi i
don't want to stop eating red meat every
night
but you i want you to get a shot that
may or may not work so that i can feel a
little better it's like dude take care
of yourself
the issue is they believe the vaccines
will work
however it's easier just to say
safety over freedom that's why i always
bring up that point from the guy in the
bar who's like we get the vaccine
it's on you now it's your responsibility
i'm like that's a great point he was
provex
he was bragging about how he was getting
his co his code vaccine was really
excited
and he was like and now it's your
problem because you're the one who's
gonna get sick not me
and i'm like that's right he's like a
liberal guy and i'm like that's that's
perfect logic
or people have a choice take care of
themselves they don't want to do it or
yeah so so the issue is
when it comes to fouchy when it comes to
body when it comes to all these
companies
listen imagine walmart you know they're
being told everyone's doing a coveted
passport or whatever
and they say no no we're not going to do
that because it's on the individual
well then somebody gets sick and then
sues walmart right because you can sue a
ham sandwich doesn't mean you're going
to win
so walmart's like it is easier just to
go with the flow and do whatever we're
told
because then at least we can have
plausible deniability or or reject
liability in the event someone gets sick
in our store
now we'll just back oh no no we have the
passport everybody's supposed to be
you know so i remember when i worked for
fusion they made me do this hostile
environment training
even though i had spent like several
years already in hostile environments
and so it was fairly there's some really
cool aspects to it
fairly rudimentary in my opinion at
least relevant to my experience
and i was like i was talking to the
people about why are they
you know making me do this i have
extensive field experience and conflict
in crisis
and they're like well you know it's just
good and i want insurance isn't it
well you know yeah because if i get hurt
and then i say well they didn't give me
the proper training so they're just like
it's easier to just make you do the
stupid training course you don't need to
do and waste the money
and time because in the event you get
hurt we don't want to get sick the big
problem with corporations and insurance
and all that is that they look at people
like numbers and they just treat us like
like a math equation i think that we're
i think we're seeing the same problem at
two different levels we're seeing a lack
of responsibility in people who refuse
to take care of themselves and you're
seeing a lack of responsibility
responsibility from these companies who
are like we're not having anything to do
with it you know we're not going to
assume any kind of responsibility for
whatever happens here
and they you know they don't want to be
sued i get it at the same time it's like
you need to like have some kind of
accountability like they'd rather poison
i would imagine the corporate beast of
walmart would rather poison the
population than suffer
a bankruptcy so i think about it this
way
when it comes to politics do you think
any one of these politicians actually
cares about you
they not me because they don't know who
i am no they they can't care about it
they don't even know because when they
look at the numbers look if it was
an election between 100 people between
you know and they're like okay you're
going to vote for me there's 100 people
i need to win 51 votes
you actually could care about each of
those people because you can meet them
and know
them and then actually convince them to
vote for you when it comes to a
politician who needs 50
000 votes in a local election they can't
spend time knowing everybody
so they don't care all of these systems
have
have developed that way walmart target
whatever the store is the movie theaters
they look at their numbers and they're
like we had 50 000 people come in this
week to see a movie
we don't know who they are we don't care
who they are a hundred of them got sick
okay we'll ban those people i don't know
we don't know them they're just numbers
i'll put it this way when when i look at
my youtube video account
i see it a number 250 000.
i don't know any of the people who watch
that the number is meaningless to me
and when i look at analytics i see this
in a bunch of other news outlets this is
why the media becomes what it is
they don't care about the individual
they don't care about their
ramifications
rachel maddow says donald trump an agent
of russia
and then all of a sudden she looks at
the number and the number's bigger and
she's like hey look it said 2.7
that says 3.1 we should do the same
thing again not realizing that she was
contributing to driving people insane
now i absolutely self-reflected on all
of that stuff and was like
i don't know what the solution is if
we're all you know genuinely having
these opinions and we're talking
about them and in the end many people
are driven by looking at their analytics
every company looking at their marketing
numbers every politician
not caring at the individual just doing
whatever it takes to make that number go
up but that means
people are driven by confirmation bias
so this is what happens to the media
rachel maddow is like just keep saying
the same thing over and over again the
numbers keep going up
until they can't anymore that's that's
the reality here as well
when they're looking at it's like a cost
benefit and a cost risk analysis you
know you guys
you ever see fight club where he's on
the plane and he's like
if the cost of a lawsuit is
uh is less than the cost of a recall
we'll just take the lawsuit basically
that's the way it works so you look at
fouchy you look at the government and
they're like
the cost of forcing people to stay home
is
lower than the cost of the risk should
something go bad
just make everybody stay home and we
used to be we
we came from this group of people and in
fact i'll tell you this my props to all
of the immigrants
who are you know climbing mountains and
riding trains and
wandering through 90 miles of desert to
get here because those people have more
pioneer blood in them
than most of these urban progressives
and suburban uppity do
liberals who are like i'd rather just be
safe now these people are like i'm going
to cross a mountain
and rip my feet to shred and be abused
and victimized by cartels but i'm coming
to america for that american dream
i respect that a heck of a lot more than
people who are like i just want to be
safe
it's like that meme you know the of the
shiba inu being all ripped and strong
and it's like um you know colonists
coming from europe
dying on the boat halfway there landing
on a shore with nothing but trees and
being like
i'm finding freedom america today just
keep me
safe that's what we get that's my rant
i think that the further you get from
these things the easier it becomes to
shrug it off
i think part of the reason that eastern
europe is still strong against communism
is because they
freaking remember they remember what
communism was like and once they start
to forget
it's all over i mean that was not even
30 years ago it wasn't that long ago
yeah luke luke who's been on the show
frequently i don't know where what luke
you left all your stakes here look like
luke
made his bible stakes are frozen luke we
bought all these peter luger sticks like
you got to get peter lurker
save him for me keep him in the freezer
all right they're in the freezer dude
but anyway he was born he was born in
soviet uh
the satellite state of the soviet union
but he was born into you know that that
system
made him cool left when he was a little
kid but i think it ended when he was
very young
his parents and his like uncles and
aunts went through it pretty hardcore
so he was told a lot about it i don't
think he saw with his own eyes i don't
know
if he saw horrors he doesn't really talk
about the horror a lot you really got to
kind of pry it out of him
i would you know what i'd love to do i'd
love to do like a a an ancestry analysis
of the people who support critical race
theory and
where where their grandparents were
during the civil rights movement
because i got a feeling that there's
going to be some correlation between
the status quo loving uppity do
anti-civil rights white folk and the
critical race theorists of today
either one for one or two reasons like
it was a backlash
these people you know are ashamed of
their history and ancestry they're
overtly racist their families racist and
so they're like yes
they're going to come out and admit
their racism and then do everything they
can
to recognize and acknowledge all of
these racial you know issues and
everything
i wonder about that because you
mentioned you know for luke his parents
told him
about what it was like in communism so
he naturally hates it
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you